the deal has been made between the Rams
and the Patriots are getting together in
two days we spent some time last hour
talking about the whole psychology of
whether to to elect the ball
yeah defer to the second half if the
Rams win the toss if the Patriots win
the toss yeah they take the ball
yeah no hmm I don't know what they'll do
I think they would take the ball right
now I think the way their offense is
playing and the way they're running the
football I think you might see a
different approach from Bill Belichick
and company I believe they won the toss
in the Chargers game right and they took
the ball for one of the rare times and
went right down the field I think they
have tremendous confidence in mojo
working right now I think that what they
did to the LA Chargers I mean you love
to come out and score every possession
yeah indefinitely right but I just feel
like there's gonna be an urgency by the
Patriots to come out and start fast they
haven't you know any of the Super Bowls
in the Bill Belichick Tom Brady era
three total points in eight first
quarters yeah it's amazing it's
unbelievable and and we've seen some
shakiness we've seen some nerves
remember Super Bowl 46 Tom Brady had
that safety and they dropped the flag we
were like why would they drop a flag you
know you never think of intentional
grounding on a 60-yard pass right but
they wish they've been shaky yes in past
Super Bowls and I think that hey they'll
try whether they succeed or not but I
think they'll try to come out and really
make a statement like they did against
the Charter yeah I do too I mean the way
they run the football and I think that
you know that's this is gonna be the key
matchup of the game is this Patriots
offense first the Rams defense you know
the Rams hey once again Aaron Donald and
DOMA can soothe Ava games of their lives
the last few weeks and like disciplined
within that they're gonna have to do it
one more time to win this football game
there's so many things I look at but you
talked about like the Patriots coming
out their pace of play how they how they
just they line up with the line of
scrimmage set hut and it's a run this
way and I'll run that way and a
play-action pass the one thing I worry
about you've heard me say all week and
I'm sick of saying it really is I do
worry about the Rams depth I know that I
worry also about the Rams lining up this
is something that has been a common
theme as I evaluate the Rams and even in
the Saints game there was a number of
plays where they're still talking to
each other and Drew Brees is snapping
the ball well I could tell you all old
Billy ball game Bella
sees that and he's going to test their
communication and get up to the line of
scrimmage and do things like that very
quickly be important for the rams to get
off a good start and you know the other
factor we haven't really talked about in
this game like I've missed this and and
I'm mad at myself for it but the James
White factor I mean New England of
course how could they not look at that
Saints game and go look at Alban camara
and look at the approach the Rams took
and we can do the same things with James
White so they're the the Rams defense is
going to have to have some wrinkles for
the back out of the backfield so they
just don't feed off of that and get
James White one-on-one with the
linebacker time after time after time
that could be an issue as well and it
was that comment from Bill Belichick
over the weekend about the Wade Phillips
defense and how it hasn't changed right
in 30 years and it sounded like praise
and and there was buzz around the league
that that's really not praise if
anything that's a a subtle warning that
Bill Belichick is gonna know exactly
what needs to be done now it didn't
necessarily help three years ago in the
AFC Championship game when the Broncos
beat the Patriots but different times
different place different we know
haven't paid we know the more balanced
the Patriots struggle in Denver right
anyway especially in the postseason and
they threw the ball 50 something times
that game they had no run game that year
if you remember for the Patriots that's
what's different about them is the first
year Brady's in the Superbowl since his
early Super Bowls where it's not about
Brady you know and I don't mean that in
like a bad way Brady's the man I'm just
saying they're really he said it
yesterday the life the heartbeat of
their football team is their offensive
line this year and what they do there
and a lot of this was their successes is
predicated off of that think about the
chain of events last February Tom Brady
has 505 passing yards in the Super Bowl
right and they lose two months later
they draft Sony Michele in round one and
a right tackle in round one and so hey
here's what we're doing we are
committing to the run because we know
especially at Tom Brady's age yes you
don't want him to have to be that
sitting duck back there 50 times a game
right because he's not going to stay on
the field if he's getting pass rushed
that often and you know you put it best
in the aftermath of the Chiefs game
running the ball on 3rd and 5 running
the ball on 3rd and 4 running the ball
on 3rd and 6th right that takes a lot of
steam out of the pass rush because as
you're trying to get to the quarterback
Michels running right by you right and
we could see that over and over again
early in this game yeah we definitely
could and I think that's you know again
I think the early part of the game we
know every part of the game is important
but the early part especially the Rams
got to get some stops if they're on
their defense is on the field a whole
lot I do worry about them you know
because of that lack of depth and all of
that and I also worry about a young
football team like the Rams if they got
down ten nothing to the Patriots early
in the Super Bowl
you know what any athletes gonna go woah
okay maybe we don't know what we're
dealing with here and it's the Super
Bowl Patriots and this is our first time
here and all of those things so I do
think that started the game and as we
talked about a million times with the
Patriots self Scout by self okay because
winning in Knight is not make that sound
so intelligent when I put the dye there
but then the biggest thing is you know
what you're just talking about with Wade
Phillips right I mean Wade Phillips Bell
Belichick 30 years I've been playing the
same defense well Wade you better have a
few wrinkles for old Billy ball game
because if you're gonna do the same
things you've been doing for 30 years I
was there in New England one of the
times we played a Wade Phillips Houston
Texans defense and yes the the the
Patriots were very comfortable with the
game plan going into those games and
you've got to throw a few curveballs and
disguise Mike disguise is huge Brady's
not gonna be tricked but at least maybe
make him think oh that's this coverage
and they he snaps he gets the ball and
he looks up and he goes oh no it's a
different coverage those little things
just little minut things can really help
a football team out after the Patriots
came back from down 28 to three two
years ago to beat the Falcons Tom Brady
said there is nothing that anyone can
show me that I have already seen and he
retains the physical ability to take
what he sees before the snap and find
the open military laser right two years
later he's got even more in that
database that he can draw upon and
experiences and everything he's seen an
experience I think that's been the thing
that sold me like after the Patriots
lost to the Dolphins of that crazy
Tillis finished with Gronk on the field
playing defense and then after they lost
to the Steelers like okay they've got to
manageable games they get a little help
in week 16 or 17 they're still gonna get
there by the experience factors gonna
kick in and they're gonna be right back
in the Superbowl and I started saying
then they're gonna be right
back of why here it comes yeah they're
setting us up they're gonna be back in
the Superbowl and here they are and you
look at their experience and you
mentioned the possibility of the Rams
team being broken right mentally and I
remember back in the 70s and the 80s
when there would be a blowout in the
Super Bowl it would typically happen
when one team fell behind by 10 or more
points the one time that flipped was
Superbowl 22 when the Broncos were up 10
nothing after one quarter in Washington
just exploded yeah 35 in the second
quarter but usually it was you get
broken and I feel like this Rams team
can get broken that's why I've been
saying all week I know you have a
blowout because I think Belichick Brady
they're gonna understand the value of
jumping on this team early and the
potential for getting one of these guys
to snap somebody's gonna be grabbing a
necklace somebody's gonna be stomping on
someone's arm somebody's gonna do
something when the pressure kicks in and
they feel it start to slip away because
they've never had it slip away on a
stage like this before well you know I'm
throwing the challenge flag on there
there big guy it's erroneous on all
accounts erroneous save for the game and
winking just to get my face I think I
able I will be absolutely I'm gonna call
you what am I gonna call you next week
if it's a blowout
what did I say stabled whatever genius
whatever i calling you you're gonna call
me super cheap super genius all next
week I don't think that's going on a
week but hey the Bram's were down 13
nothing in the Superdome against the rim
I mean against the Saints and they came
back I don't think they're gonna be
overly flustered I know it's a Super
Bowl but it also won't be a home-field
advantage type crowd it's a Super Bowl
crowd so that's where I'll just push
back at you Oh Mike Florio let me say
this yeah if they get down 13 nothing
this time and whatever switch flip two
weeks ago doesn't flip now and it
becomes 16 or 20 that's when well I'll
say this that's when it's move to your
point if they make some of the mistakes
they made early in the New Orleans game
I can promise you that that Brady and
company are not gonna settle for field
goals and that where is it could be a
blowout so if they don't come out and
play a smart football game if Gurley
drops a pass and it gets intercepted and
then you know the Patriots have this
short field twice the Patriots are not
going to miss out on those opportunities
I would agree with you there but I think
the Rams I just think the Rams are the
more
talented football team that's what
scares me I'm picking the Patriots as
you know but I I do think the Rams are
more talented but it's not just about
talent in football it is about depth
schematic so many things situational
football so many things go into winning
a football game and the Masters of that
are the New England Patriots Fran
Tarkenton yeah John Elway right Jim
Kelly yeah do you know what club they're
in well they all went they lost more
than two Super Bowl lost consecutive
Super Bowl second only quarterbacks who
yes consecutive Super Bowls right I
think the one factor we cannot overlook
yeah Tom Brady doesn't want to join that
Club yeah I know I still pissed about
what happened last night here yes Tom
Brady's gonna do everything in his power
man to me every I mean he you can't you
see it happening in the locker room
before the game he is gonna go to every
guy and he is gonna make sure that they
see what they're gonna have to deal with
if they lose that game cuz he's not
losing two in a row well I mean yeah
sure he's gonna be competitive as hell I
mean we know that but you know they're
not like God I mean I know they're
really freaking good but it's funny you
said cuz if he'd walk up here right now
you would Genya fly if Tom wash his feet
if Tom Brady was here right now yes I
love Tom Brady you know that I do that's
why I hate when people say I'm a Tom
Brady hater drives me crazy because you
mentioned he cheated every chance you
get I would say that to him to his face
- I go you know what I'm asking his feet
I would go on that you did that cuz you
were like my idol and I'm mad you did
that that's all I would say to him and
then I'd get over it he might punch me
in the face right there or something but
I would just go okay sorry I had to get
it off my chest I like you a lot
but your points I hear all of that I do
I understand that and I think it's a
tool to a degree it's one of the reasons
I do feel the Patriots will win the game
- because I'm just like I can't picture
them winning losing two Super Bowls in a
row that can't happen in this football
team but I don't think it's going to be
a blowout not this day and age this Rams
team is tough they are battle tested
they went through a bad part of the year
and I would be shocked if they're not
within one score at the end of this
football game nine twenty just like
Super Bowl Tom you love it I can't
believe he's going with that big
defensive coordinator it was built
ballots here right
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports